we were doing at Netflix happen to be
this conference in 2019 and then after
that the open source bunch of followers
in this talk and lower some of the work
that the team did over the last service
like five more years
so
for those of you who are either
practicing data scientists are
responsible for building or provisional
infrastructure for data science
decided about
based on fight
instead of like four sticker prices that
are thinking about or sort of activity
involved in introducing some kind of
intelligence
applications usually they'll start with
some business problems
we need data scientists would be tasked
with
this metric
the very first step after my journey of
introducing machine learning to a
business
would involve some kind of an ID
might sort of like uh
you know like I was getting more and
more common these days we need to do
with my own book uh on a cloud instance
sure
which is sort of like a great way for a
data scientist to get started you know
sort of
like keeps many other details and so
that's a great start
now the first thing that you know
absolutely machine learning platform
builders that you have to sort of like
immediately worry about necessarily how
do we certainly connect to a whole bunch
of different data sources
sort of like different ideas that use it
in sort of you know using and uh space
themselves not only how you're doing
data from your data warehouses
or technical concerns avoid this data in
the first case uh and whatnot so what
what we sort of like okay Do You observe
during Netflix was that any kind of
machine that impact on the foundation is
you
computer making noise and analyzing that
you know in that equipment
but there's usually some form of the
results uh many times the
Cloud instance.com that's our individual
Network that's all good and enough for
that uh
the three times you want to sort of like
you know spell over to adoption so if
you want to train a model that requires
two games
attached to your interpreted instance
and how do you sort of like you know
lift and shift to your computer
maybe you know if you want to train
multiple different models and factors if
you're like some data processing still
that requires
these days you can very easily get one
of these super exotic instances
only 10 years ago
um
but then a big bottle like still sort of
thing exists for a data scientist how do
I sort of get your personality how do I
think about what how do I think about
kubernetes
is sure if that uh the data that I was
able to access online
foreign
specifically to just sort of like move
productive onto that data engineering
now one sort of like key difference
between machine learning workflows and
uh
this notion of
titration
you're certainly constantly iterating
through a list of different hypothesis
so I'll take one between uh on different
kinds of features and whatnot maybe you
want to run similar uh trading workflows
but on your hyper parameters
there's constant experimentation that's
happening and there's like a strong lead
to version everything like this
what are all the experiments that you're
asking
experiments uh how is sort of like you
know manufacturing sort of like making
tasks
and then once you have let's say some
kind of model
then comes sort of thing from the notion
of who finds that model now within an
organization
machine learning projects and each of
those projects specific requirements of
other climates I mean of course that
Netflix you know what one of the
spectrum
Edition systems uh where the slas were
really high
directories modern posting Services it
was sort of like really taking school
and requires sort of like constant
attention
years of devops point of view on the
other end of the spectrum you also have
many other applications that were in
many ways driving as much business
certification systems to the UPS have
never seen or something you know uh very
sort of like you know one requests
Department
you can imagine by Netflix are sort of
like usually invested in
you know the bleeding edge of its
recommendation systems uh every single
year it also spends 25 million dollars
curating a portfolio content
applications
you may have models that are deployed
inside cell phones you may have bodies
investigated some schools
pricing strategy for service operations
deployments can come in from the radio
different sheets and cycles and it was
important for us
like our communities
and then you know if we look at sort of
like you know the story the stack is
sort of like building up and now we're
getting into this
basically only spoken about engineering
and services
at least he sort of like you know this
uh stack emerging at the end of the day
uh where from a data scientist point of
view what they would ideally want to
focus on is basically the very top level
of the stuff that's where
um their uh primary skill sets I uh
that's what they are motivational side
and here give me a business problem and
I would want to sort of like translate
that problems
what's the best way to sort of like
optimize certain metrics uh but then I'm
yet to sort of like you know very many
data scientists who really care about
like okay how is the data actually
stored in the data warehouse from an
hdfs S3s as long as they know what is
the deal that are stored for you guys
access case
it's a similar story with compute as
well
um folks want access to the fusion
sources
those are sort of like implementation
foreign
you know
and
now the question becomes that okay if
yeah
what is it
um
and the other sort of like group based
learning that we had
during that time was if you look at sort
of like you know the open source
universe or the advancements that were
happening outside of organizations like
Netflix both of the machine learnings
those are convinced right I mean if you
look back let's say 15 years ago 16
years ago
um the average instance that you would
find on ews would have like 1.6 gigs of
is
programming Paradise it was not very
many problems could be solved from those
certain things but now you can go out
and you can get instances which are like
fix everything you know you know uh much
more massive problems on a single
instant
not advances
machine learning side of the house as
well ten years ago 15 years ago when
Netflix started sort of like you know
focusing on recommendations uh the users
have been actual
office by themselves but these days
like
um there's also a lot of app
arent businesses they progress they
matured up they do they sort of like uh
every
sort of like a one person drop game in
any specific business metric requires a
lot of heavy duty work really you know
you can't sort of like cut this red eye
on any closed Cloud solution so there's
a huge demand for sort of effective
distinguishing building and the quickly
yeah
like going out and hiring excellent uh
data scientists but then for them to
actually deliver business value not only
do they have to be trade I think that's
nice
so so we ended up building
um
we spoke about the project uh here at
Thailand November 2019 in December 2016
um
if you're interested in sort of like you
know trying out my doctor and thinking
by the time we recently brush out and
started a company as well called copper
bounds and we'll be able to sort of like
find a hosted demo on a browser that we
can start taking a quick demo we'll see
another talk as well so Dr certificate
so yeah data scientists at your
workplaces who are interested
so any uh python function that's perfect
allocate with that step becomes the node
in your graph and when you see first let
me set up next certification that
becomes sort of like the edge between
different words and you get features
like a variety of different structures
as long as yourself like very important
directories like a graphs
how to define your workflows
and now and it's sort of like you know
this notion of sort of like providing
these access uh now many organizations
we also exist can that way against its
nice spark interest
also an actual effect
investment
what we observed was most data
scientists what they really want is that
certain partitions of a given data uh
table that let's say you're data
engineering team or some sort of like
other ETL processes
and usually it's far more performant if
the input of the order of like 20 25
gpps which can be higher than the local
desktops attached to that compute
instance and what that means is that as
the data scientist as I trade in over
different data sets they can actually
sort of directly accessible
sort of like to appreciate the impact
now that two minutes so now every single
execution uh that happens with metaphor
that automatically is Fortune it's a
cycle
and the entire internal State um so you
can sort of like go back in time and say
like okay here's my colleague I want to
know something like you know six months
ago if they excluded about you what was
the internal state of that workflow what
was the value of an alpha so it's like
you know of an integer or fluid in this
case it could be a model object you can
have something more options and that
sort of like provides people is an easy
way to sort of like go back in time
observe not only their work but their
colleagues work as well you can build up
essentially depend on the other issues
and their business
now all of this is sort of like you know
great when you are so that can find you
a simple instance but as I mentioned
right like many times uh the few
distance from which are running your
workflow on your work it may not be
optimal
so in this decorator basically what's
happening is that automatically use a
screen step will run on your remote a
few clusters could be equivalent to
Cluster on-prem and any of the three
popular clouds it could be an AWS patch
Computing environment and the user
doesn't really have to think about
anything else is
interactive logs right back to their
computers and uh it is
like just walked in and
foreign
and then of course you know like um uh
the one thing that I've spoken about was
if it's all good in fine as long as
yourself like executing and trading from
within Global stations will help but
then there comes a time when you want to
select things to run some kind of like
sketch you will have the good thing is
that it's very likely that your
organized
organizers
maybe it's that functions feel very
faster what not all of these will flow
orchestrators what they promise is
highly available execution of a tab and
a bit better for you a really sort of
executed about that
so we are able to compile down meta flow
tag into that that these systems
understand and now in part of a sudden
we basically you get the message
protocols now the good thing here is
every single thing is also getting
snapshot it here so now so now if let's
say uh in your peace notes fail and
actually go back to your laptop
and fix it and
it's not going to remember you have to
stay tuned and then uh
so it's like really simplifies your
development moving into production
and then of course you know bunch of
other
features that we have introduced
one sort of like big question that likes
another people is um dependency
management uh if this thing we need to
sort of like astrology it's up to even
go about doing that okay because it was
like really learning markets
like you know some historical context uh
so at Netflix operationally there used
to be this OnePlus Property Data
scientists would use foreign
dependencies as well and certain
snapshot those dependencies and ensure
that humidity Upstream repository or
whatever reasons goes away your
confidence to continue to work without
any issue uh of course a bunch of other
features which are more focused on sort
of like collaboration of that group
together workflows you can imagine a
scenario we have users who have let's
say a chain of workflows that's what the
fact regular one after the other but
then now if let's say a new data
scientist comes in and they want to sort
of like for the entire chain and execute
that kind of want to make sure that they
don't end up overwriting any of your
results and things can sort of
background and nicely right now so those
are all the galaxies
uh so yeah so this was sort of like a
big
um roughly 10 minutes and I ran through
this because
um so it's like just give a quick demo
um of everything that I've spoken about
um if you're ever interested
um
all along as well
for you
uh but basically if you go to amazon.com
which is the website
for free and uh this is basically TQ to
this hosted PS4 experience
um so here we see sort of like you know
a very simple three-step workflow so we
have the start set the start step sort
of identifies yourself dot next uh
uh command which is perfect means that
will show uh to executed
and if I execute this workflow you can
see sort of like I might have to
executing this workflow and assigning a
run ID to this worker so every execution
automatically gets assigned a unique
credit and you can see sort of like all
different statements uh showing up here
to sort of like you know a nice little
UI as well that allows
and you can see um
uh one functionality is the solution of
adaptive parts
and also many times
you will uh it's actually that every
single time
it's you should have this type of
application
so
uh
this volume text that you see that sort
of like guiding you through like what
really happened is
um
so that was sort of like you know a
simple uh example of a linear flu uh you
can have sort of a notion of process
where you want to run this the workflows
or like steps and tablet uh that sort of
like super simple and straightforward so
rather than sort of like I said dot next
to specifying one node you can specify
multiple groups so now if that's you
know I execute this it actually quite 10
seconds
us
so you'll see sort of like you know at
this point uh run ID 5 is assigned here
and this workflow starts executed and we
need 10 degrees that we are now
executing in public and the author is
that countries
um
[Music]
this card over here this is
an emotional perfect Market accent
versioning um
anything
assigned to
in a situated for example Asus affected
by two that gets involved by you know so
of course you know like if this was in
the opportunity so if I can put you
would expect sort of like the self.take
simplified then you know the value of x
and incrementing it by one the relying
pressure can be six uh which is
basically is here
um then uh let's see sort of like might
have to just like how to log into all of
these different values with an
ultimately you have stored and the user
doesn't really have to sort of like take
any explicit action uh finances to
record in
uh all the logs are also stored in
perpetually
okay
the logs for a specific work for that
exclusion that's in your back and then
if we even answer ing user actually
having to figure out however
all these gods and just have questions
and Storage
now
I want to sort of like another dimension
of let's say hyper parameters
previous example one of the previous
examples we saw sort of like how you
could even touch it uh here's an example
of running let's say you know um uh this
step multiple times for different set of
animals what we are doing here is your
essentially instructing the workflow to
execute the process step but for each
element of this list of data so we'll
run sort of like you know two copies of
the process that we see here
that's what technique is actually really
easy for people to run very simple basic
type of applications
now all of this sort of like you know at
this point is running
on this PS4 workstation
kubernetes uh decorator so by defaulted
let's say
A Part which will have a single CPU and
four bits of ram so
sectors basically what's going to happen
is that the stock step is going to run
opening on my laptop and then
the process step I will run three copies
of the process step in the cloud and the
user didn't have felt like worry about
Hardware authenticate with kubernetes
clustered uh what are sort of like you
know variety of different kubernetes
objects however to think about sort of
like normalizing my code and pushing it
to the cloud uh all the logs will be
fetched
came in that sort of places I didn't
extract resources to them out so let's
see start breaking up for example these
processing statements
shows for example this processing Apple
this command is actually this
instruction executed will improve this
so so that's that sort of like you know
sometimes before would be uh forms of
magnesium today in this town
now in one of the steps basically what
we're going to do is we are talking
a lot of memories and that's likely that
you know like you know you don't really
sort of like a lot of resources
available on your laptop because this
deck was actually going to help me so we
can actually catch failures as well and
update sort of like fail the entire
workflow with let's say one shot case
for whatever reason but then if you want
to sort of like you know more resources
so this is this is basically uh you know
some of the product features like the
basic functionality you're made up to of
course you want to demo let's say
so only just by typing our Google screen
I can sort of like move my workflow so
for those of you who are familiar with
our Google Plus
has such a number of different things so
I sort of making sure that Here
and Now basically when I execute this
flow and now execute this
I can come here
because this is sort of like a standard
if you can talk here as well
this is
and now I have for example write this on
the stock and I distributed this hello
and you can see sort of like this
particular identify it's a new type of
cargo virtue
uh but then if you go to met up to a UI
as well you would like to see
just like make sure you're um has a
better flow of your as well and you
basically at this point you're getting
the minutes like support
um
investment and if let's say for whatever
reason
I go back to here
and there's a site let's dominate this
and
then basically what I can do is
this thing here
and I can ask I might have to resume
that code
available
you want an opportunity
of chamber uh what really went wrong and
the first step to debugging any issue is
to replicate that is
and
for example in this particular case
because I had behind kubernetes
decorator the process let us delivered
so yeah that's basically it's a quick
challenge and we are also almost started
yes
uh yes indeed so we are just about to
release an integration with gcp uh so a
month ago we released an integration
with passion
so it is
thank you
thank you so I'm sorry you were like
manually allocating everything
so you can set the performance so if you
don't specify whether it be
taken care of impossible you can always
specific memory or CPU
yes
I think I sort of stopped you had a
snowflake Warehouse logo
um I've seen a lot in my previous job
that a lot of data scientists have
reached for the warehouse and they would
do a lot of stuff in the warehouse and
then they were trying to pull it into
their python process and do some stuff
how does that tend to work in practice
100 gigabytes of the network that are
destroying in memories
yeah excellent question you know
many times some users do that's going to
sort of like push the feeding down
synthesis
and then get the final results
let's say uh snowflake plant are people
to support through just like playing SQL
need
and loss of like pull down the road is
shut down uh maybe sort of make another
set of problems that we are interested
in of that industry and then use quite a
few very quickly
let's say
yes
[Music]
it was that
looking orchestration but there's still
being Argo on gkd or targeting Cube flow
so the orchestration layer for gcp would
be airflow and cargo
and
a few users are overviews
um it looked like what you were doing
was you sort of had a python file and
you would sort of run it and that would
get submitted maybe to your kubernetes
I'm curious how you do sort of like code
versioning or change management along
with that uh such that you know only
things that have sort of been approved
and merged into your main branch or
something end up getting run on the
production system
see others I mean there are two things
right like so one is understanding what
code was ever executed so anytime you
execute any Miracle view we actually
sort of like snapshot the code and here
I store that ns3 for you uh and then now
the other question about sort of
Technology
changes are effective workflows so when
you find users they sort of declare only
talks philosophy
yeah so you know many organizations for
uh you know data privacy Jesus they may
not want to give data scientists direct
access to certain specific S3 buckets
and those scenarios people will sort of
like work on some curated data set token
and then submit their product review and
then mastered user like this room in the
cicd process will basically execute the
exact same command that I'm execute in
here but then only help the customer
um
which is
because you you also mentioned sort of
at Netflix having some Docker image that
had you know the correct versions of all
the libraries I I assume in order for
this to run in an Argo workflow you
would similarly need some kind of Base
Docker image type for each of the Yeah
so basically if you want to submit
Heroes like if you want to specify your
own image all you need to do is
business
and they will use this image instead
of business
is there like a management in a place
called provision compute power and
memory optional accomplishment
users uh yes so there are sort of like
International Visa
so of course we have sort of thing they
put off cloud formation interface that
allow you to configure a private amount
of computers available including entire
organization
Republicans
but then there are definitely
of course you would want sort of like
you know something you got let's say a
hundred thousand pay for each and take
over the entire cluster so then
there's something a large amount of
exclusion called reaction sort of like
the user and dedication by businesses
any other questions
so
there's a word what's the exploration uh
probably depends on how you want to say
yes
so basically you you sort of technique
is it
foreign